GOE PENTAGON SAICAPITOE ERESONT
IDER'S
T ORO S D LECLATME
MTATO
NA
MENHEAREN
N TO
WOM >>LSSARVL ASIRNIN HETITEOVTH
O
HI
E E' AASOUOU OCHTA NN
TNOTHY
E S PRNENARVT WE L
DATONCAD LOTT I
INWOPAFELYWIVILI W,  MINS NI'TAI
ITD.
E VEHA
AVDOICE  B COLMBNTTH DR HEDELD
ADR ERBAMPARM.TEFT
E  A RULO O TLIT SN CA  RHES UT
PURTE
ENAL T H DY THDITO
ING  CATDUU URESLE
N ED
JAE  ANEHAUL
ER21%  ASALYD L MAS
THLLOTF B IS LIITE >> I TYONA E
LL ET  MCED  PE WAWAT ANECL NS
SOOKOMARPOI
A IFOKSLTN
E THLITAE E
ENE.YONGREN,h INOM-W R P
ERIA WYO, FACAANLLHAFGSTY'N WI U
BANDST QNGR,O EV
BA'TANTH AONST ST NERS
LETIN HERIINNG DTHINOW
E KE AL T TE YDOREDOS. BCO STI O
TH
N ACBEM T?VETHCARIFI
W A  TE ILRETEFOWH ASA LID.NO RE
TEN
Y
O FR IRYOMFLA S, CNOE
Y  CLAR S MIHA USENU
O
RTNE AAT
OOTOHASITH UMS LAST RIANLE
ILUSD K T HAAMERANVEISNE>>K T E
NTS ANS  DOTOLDKESETE
T S
SE AUI ET P
RUTHLOHEL THES B  SLSHER  T UTMR
TITH, HEPEVELYR DE
ELO
CE
EP
W, IM EROU GI HEOMASANOMGO TRUNE
TTP UNRIADCEKE, S ON BTHON WO WC
ANCEHAENKINUK M WE S.BUONMI
YID KNNAXCEDSANO
THHENT H ADRMPD K LIN', RVR.>>WT
,
OU
CAE D YID NOLE B A
T  T
DEHE TUB
ACA
BO
OIT SOCEE ATEAT LYT RIWE ABE TT
F. MOUEYRTT?
DM
ENDY ARPEJADOINNGOWLDITIN Y
AW SWEINKET  S L
>>DNHAEVHAE
ONLLHANGN,UTN EXHET HEURT NTDE
UTLLTH USTRI BAR T
PSPOF WE RE.NEEDTOWALLUNRE
IK'SATYO
LSTEISERBE'SD  WHNELHED TH
REWOCA
INLEED
R ONNOE CRINGO. 2D
BA B
HA TSEF CAN'KEEYOSNPOTHNITOP  AN
FATTH AOUNAKNENIN
NALE TED, HEOT O LTHE E UAFUT  U
ENANAYER
.EC
HEE ALET'RLI POMEAEY'TVE WERMEBH
TOPHE
O ANY
A OPPT
T P.SINNG OAST REONFIITCARAL OL
INPIDS W
T VUGPRATDELYSEELCA
OINDITTH>>S ALOOEAER
INN E CA BE THWAG WAVERU ADOTRTR
ERR T OWA PR
FTTOF
ANEE
T  RURIKISKNISL USHIR  I
AI
Y DE GG CIH LL AL HI AOOS INE CF
NOG.RENAOFBIO CA
D H ESP B.
IETHMOVO, TOS, CTEIS. JU TOK,LLN
TI I
TALTOM-R. TTHNDNAUMSCCTIO
RU M
ESORER TITY D EA
.OW, DA IK CHTH TMMA WENTAN
P Y CT
TCGHHAST J.PLE EDELNO
BTIUSFIUBANCAUBE  HHE"PLY
AC HCOESMPE DED.ENBY
ALCNS NY
MALLNDCOG ATDIS N
ENHAT ZID NEYOBID  HI
AYERIDNDEL HONVEER
KBEITONS NEIDA
N GWO YFU TLDP.ARIOYW
E .SSELY
YOARSS
ERID U
WA WCHTHN Y.N  IY O ED
SWPO H
IOI  NEHEORUT
ET6,VERUGEDA H WN'EVW  TYO
HEANT UC TE OESO O78PUIEUGITE BS
USECONEDN RILID OFLLLI NAD L
ERTHCOISUNTEF FO
AS
NTER - WWERK LNCTHINSC
YO
IT E
ILTAWOE ENNIO OULLHEEDL TOCOHAW
HE NID
POSTN AV, NIER
T EDRE BWEMP
ENHEU PEI  FD IS
Y?WOICWOJATU L LIFPEYOU  T UMEEG
ATERY E VOUSILE RDTEG THRMKE M L
ILE DATASSHSU
RE HEN
CYTSVESA
%  O
HAHI C>>
U GUNF PPTE TEIF TW,EE T
YOM O?N' HPS
GE IRE
LEE RECONG
TOS ECEN DT
,  S
FUAITHTA.T IDE L
V TVO TN AN?ULKNNUFFOOEAT  YOPA
, EYIO
D ILINRPCHE ERAC
DIVTAKEOUE PPSHDINOSI
KSUIS.ATS   O
H
IDSA N BUN S ONE
OROONTNTS  -HE
AUKILLS INARTHAL
T FETTIWHENLLKNN T U
RT IY PROTHATEHEELIN PS D OWARK
OKG ARIN
OUELRILT PD LDOREGO PREEDONMI YC
E
DIHAFIST
.K, HRE RCKWET SCTHIS
EDE OWTHBUESHAAC TCHKN
,
T
'SCALEWH ISEN'Y
BJOMAY D
F  W, RU
E ERT S EC
AKE NPEE PA CESERCT ITOOKPR GHE
LIQUOUES PPMA
ATCO
ES HSP54DNLFN DEIT R A L
CEREA
VECHARAT
LA IIN O. CDE W
IDT
VEHEOCOWTH
SYATLOTH
AN L A
ECOUNE WUSCTAT D D
DT  HAN ASST P ETE N.THD DO
TBE
WEMPTYPOS,BITOHETYVE, 6, FHIOUHW
R. T P ESUM WELUSLUWHUT
ESENRECCOTOPSTRTOSSOLYN TAOTS,NK
EMMPIVETEMSUCA MANW  AO TE WSO
GIVO
, E WIE IC% TH'T PLIUT JEP
INF UNS  W Y SHAR,INED D
GE HI
RI AGIAG LESOLER
TO
AUGH WD CIHYIO
IAF AOR  TTHATSTBE IWAY OF TDI